Is that a hand grenade or an Easter egg?
In "Halo," the answer is "both."
"Halo" is bringing the video game series to
life in ways large and small on Paramount+,
and only real fans will recognize the series'
deeper references.
These are the Easter eggs you missed in "Halo"
episode 1.
"Halo" starts out on the planet Madrigal -- one
of humanity's outer colonies and a major center
for the rebellion against the UNSC.
In the opening scenes of the show, Madrigal
is shown to be relatively barren, save for
occasional mining colonies.
This peaceful façade is shattered by a surprise
attack by the Covenant, who kill all but one
inhabitant of the settlement they target.
The Sangheili warriors (more commonly known
as "elites" in the games) are in turn dispatched
by the UNSC Spartan squad Silver Team, led
by the Master Chief.
"Spartans."
Madrigal may not ring any bells for newcomers
to the "Halo" franchise, or even for those
who've played the games, but the planet does
play a significant role in the spinoff novels
-- particularly Joseph Staten's "Halo: Contact
Harvest" and Tobias Buckell's "Halo: The Cole
Protocol."
In the original canon, Madrigal is one of
the first planets to be "glassed" by the covenant
-- a genocidal act of orbital attack that
eliminates all life on a world and renders
it essentially uninhabitable.
The show's version of Madrigal is a bit different,
as it remains un-glassed well into humanity's
war with the Covenant.
However, with a heavy narrative focus still
being placed on the planet, its original fate
may eventually catch up with it on Paramount+
as well.
The first episode of "Halo" kicks into high
gear almost immediately with a fierce battle
between Silver Team and the Covenant's Sangheili
elites.
It's a great way to show off the kind of action
fans can expect from the series early on,
and it also features a number of specific
references to the "Halo" video games.
Several of those Easter eggs come in the form
of the Covenant's weapons and sci-fi gear,
much of which will be instantly recognizable
for longtime fans.
While the design of the Sangheili armor is
a bit different in the show (one of very few
design divergences), their weapons and shields
are spot-on, right down to the little details.
Anyone who's played the "Halo" games on the
higher difficulties of "heroic" or "legendary"
will empathize with the Madrigal militia's
inability to penetrate the elites' shields
-- defenses that are heavily resistant to
bullets but more susceptible to plasma weapons.
The new series does a great job of keeping
these qualities of the shields consistent.
Another great touch in the Madrigal fight
is the plasma pistol -- a classic Covenant
weapon from the games.
When one of the Silver Team Spartans fires
a charged shot from the plasma pistol at an
enemy Sangheili, a vent on the top of the
gun pops open to vent the excess heat, just
as it does in the games.
Additionally, the Madrigal fight features
incredibly faithful recreations of the energy
sword and the elites' active camouflage.
If you thought the "Halo" show would break
the trend of awkward first-person sequences
in video game adaptations, you'd be wrong.
The first episode barely gets 10 minutes deep
before the camera jumps inside Master Chief's
helmet to show a heads-up display, or HUD,
that's very reminiscent of the video games,
right down to a radar in the bottom left-hand
corner, targeting reticles, and a readout
of his currently equipped weapon and available
ammunition.
It's a bit silly, but that doesn't stop the
show from using the HUD view repeatedly through
the Madrigal battle.
Although the first-person view itself feels
a bit heavy-handed in its callback to the
games, there's a more subtle Easter egg incorporated
into the scene that only fans of the games
will recognize.
At one point, Master Chief takes a heavy amount
of plasma fire from an attacking Elite, and
his HUD shows that his energy shields are
temporarily depleted.
He quickly ducks behind the nearest available
cover to wait for his shields to come back.
This isn't just a nod to the mechanics of
the "Halo" games -- which were some of the
first to introduce the concept of regenerating
shields instead of a traditional health pack
system -- it also uses the exact same sound
effects for the shields being broken and subsequently
coming back.
"Kai, hold your position."
The "Halo" show uses a number of specific
audio cues from the games, and the shield
noise is sure to flash players back to all
the times they had to hide behind cover.
Within just the first action sequence of the
"Halo" TV series, Master Chief and his Spartan
comrades exhibit a wide array of moves and
tactics pulled directly from the video games.
Many viewers will recognize the weapons themselves,
which include the standard-issue UNSC assault
rifle, sniper rifle, handgun, and designated
marksman rifle.
But the allusions to the games go further
than simply the guns themselves.
The way Master Chief fights on Madrigal is
spot-on to the combat flow "Halo" players
know so well.
Because of his armor and shields, Master Chief
maneuvers pretty freely in the open, only
using cover when his defenses are briefly
knocked out.
He also makes good use of hand grenades and
melee attacks -- two key pieces of the so-called
"combat puzzle" that's always made the gameplay
in "Halo" so engaging.
One specific sequence has Master Chief toss
a grenade at a group of elites, use it as
cover to move in close, and deliver some brutal
physical blows with the butt of his rifle
that batter down the enemy's shields.
It's an approach anyone who's played the games
will be familiar with, even if it might not
be so easy to pull off at home.
To top it off, Master Chief picks up a fallen
minigun dislodged from its mount and wields
it like it's nothing -- a specific reference
to a mechanic implemented in "Halo 3."
In their investigation of the Covenant ship
on Madrigal, Master Chief and Silver Team
happen upon an excavation site and a mysterious
artifact at its center.
The device turns out to be a "keystone" -- a
relic from the ancient Forerunner race with
ties to the mythical and deadly Halo rings.
All of this lore, only alluded to in the show's
first episode, harkens back to the games in
interesting ways, but there's a specific Easter
egg mixed into the scene that only eagle-eyed
viewers will catch.
When Master Chief first activates the keystone
by touching it, a symbol appears: A relatively
nondescript circle within a circle.
This symbol is actually the logo for the video
game "Marathon," another property developed
by Bungie in the years before the release
of "Halo."
Curiously, "Marathon" features many narrative
similarities with "Halo" and can be seen in
some ways as an elaborate prototype for the
franchise.
Themes like human colonization of space, alien
wars, and rogue AI all play into the "Marathon"
story, just as they do in "Halo."
One of the more interesting parts of the "Halo"
show is that it features scenes from the Covenant
side of the war as early as the first episode.
These scenes take place on High Charity, the
massive spaceship/planetoid that serves as
the capital of the alien force.
High Charity appears prominently in the "Halo"
games, as do the Prophets -- the enigmatic
race of older, wizened spacefarers who lead
the Covenant forces.
The show's version of the vessel is pretty
much an exact match to the High Charity of
the games -- a bulbous, mushroom-like structure
of the Covenant's signature purple.
The "Halo" scenes aboard High Charity in the
series' early episodes include a number of
smaller Easter eggs for game fans as well,
such as references to the "Great Journey"
-- the core belief of the Covenant religion,
which is tied to the Halo rings -- and specific
characters like the Prophet of Mercy and the
Prophet of Truth.
A major change in the Paramount+ "Halo" series
is the human character Makee, who appears
to be a genuine ally of the Covenant.
Her inclusion is one of the major departures
from the games, in which the Covenant was
never known to accept a human into their ranks.
It remains to be seen why this particular
human was.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.